flippy from indiana
flippy from indiana please unmute you
are on the air my friend all right can
you hear me
yes i can
hey david it's me um i just was
wondering if you've ever reconsidered
making an only fans sorry if i if i've
done making an omelette what no no
making it only fans uh you know
earning season is over and it's time for
you to show us your zucchini
that's very clever no listen um i think
i'd be more likely
uh i'd be more likely to show my my
granny smith apples than any zooks
floppy dukes flippy floppy uh floppy
dukes
[Music]
floppy dukes flippy floppy
five and a quarter inches
today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the china virus that
will
save countless lives
[Music]
to help treat patients battling a
current infection convalescence
today i'm pleased to
make a truly historic announcement in
our battle against the china virus that
will
save countless lives
we provided 48 million dollars to fund
the mayo clinic study that tested the
efficacy of
convalescence
[Music]
convalescent
[Music]
convalescent
i have with me david pakman he is a
progressive host
an executive producer of the
nationally syndicated radio and tv
program the david pacman show
and i wanted to talk to david patman
he is a baby
[Music]
david pacman
he is
[Music]
[Music]
can you remind the audience when you
talk about being a beta male and being
an alpha male what what are we talking
about here
there are males most men today yeah male
1 they think and act like a woman they
are emotional
they are mentally off they have no logic
and that's a beta male they go along
with homosexuality hold on but whoa whoa
jesse well we gotta that's a lot
that's a lot hang on agree with
everything that's raw abortion they
think and act just like a woman a beta
male died but another baby
doesn't because he's a logical thinking
and they're controlled by the darkness
of david pakman
[Music]
[Music]
ten
times elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
ten times
elements of
[Music]
what on bathrooms
is going on with trump and toilets
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
[Music]
with documents that donald trump was
flushing down the toilet
[Music]
is this the explanation is this the
explanation
big massive dumps
elements of
bathrooms ten times
[Music]
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
hard to imagine a more serious
introduction to today's stream uh
welcome everybody so much is going on
it is um
it's sometime in march or april i guess
today i don't even know when it is but
we're here live it's certainly the first
half of the year that much i know
and unfortunately circumstances are
getting increasingly dangerous for the
media and press and reporters
in ukraine and we're going to go through
that
and it's really not good it's really
it's really not good um welcome glad
everybody's joining me the podcast is
out
some youtube clips are out
and i don't even know
exactly where to start but i i guess
we'll start here
uh brett renaud whoops clicked off of it
u.s journalist and filmmaker killed in
ukraine
now this was originally misreported as
new york times journalist
brett has not actually done any
freelance work for the new york times
since 2015 doesn't matter doesn't make
the story any less tragic but it was
initially reported
as new york times reporter and then it
became you know believed that he was
actually there reporting for the new
york times he wasn't doesn't matter
still extraordinarily tragic what's
going on there uh he was this report
says 50 years old another says 51 i mean
it seems some details are still uh sort
of being figured out
keeve's police chief says he was
targeted by russian soldiers
um
oh hold on a second i gotta ban a couple
people i apologize
it's already getting toxic in the chat
um first reported death of a foreign
journalist covering the war in ukraine
one of the injured journalists told an
italian reporter he had been with renaud
when they came under fire we were across
one of the first bridges in eurpin
going to film other refugees leaving and
we got into a car
somebody offered to take us to the other
bridge and we crossed the checkpoint and
they start shooting at us so the driver
turned around and they kept shooting
there's two of us my friend is brent
renaud and he says brent yeah okay so
for a second i thought there was a
conflict there and he's been shot and
left behind i saw him being shot in the
neck so
these
obviously this happened and there is no
reason to question that it was russian
forces and not ukrainian forces
that's not under dispute
in addition there are increasingly
videos which i'm not going to play just
because i don't know
you know what exactly the limits are on
what we're allowed to show
um there are videos now
in mario paul
very clearly of russian tanks just
firing on civilian apartment buildings
and again
will russia have some explanation i'm
sure my guess is they'll say it was
being used as a staging location
for uh
you know who the hell knows right for
for
combatants or whatever the case may be
but uh as of this particular moment we
don't have any reason to believe that
that's what's going on now at the same
time just hours ago
we learned that another reporter has
been wounded this is fox news reporter
benjamin hall
here is a report from fox news
john roberts explaining
what he knew at the time anyway you're
now this from the chief executive
officer officer of fox news suzanne
scott
who sent a message to the network today
saying earlier today our correspondent
benjamin hall
was injured while news gathering outside
of kiev in ukraine we have a minimal
level of details right now but ben is
hospitalized and our teams on the ground
are working to gather additional
information as the situation quickly
unfolds the safety of our entire team of
journalists in ukraine and the
surrounding regions is our top priority
and of the utmost importance
this is a stark reminder for all
journalists who are putting their lives
on the line every day to deliver the
news from the war zone we will update
everyone as we know more please keep ben
and his family in your prayers so there
is john roberts delivering the statement
published earlier today by fox news uh
who is it that published this uh someone
from the daily beast okay
so uh unfortunately it's been becoming
increasingly dangerous
even for the press
and um again
you know we continue to follow
the progress or lack thereof
of the russian invasion itself
but then there become these
stories that are inextricably embedded
with it like for example the treatment
of and violence against members of the
media
and reporters so a lot happening all at
the same time
i want to talk about the forthcoming
address from zelensky of the u.s a joint
session of the house and senate i'm
going to talk about that momentarily
a super chat hello kintu says from the
standpoint of water
how much drip would you say trump
currently possesses that i don't know
that that i really don't know
um i do want to say thank you to bobby
and jen here for the twitch prime
subscriptions putting us at two i i do
genuinely appreciate that
very very much
um let me see if i had anything else
over here
no i think i'm fine over there okay
let's continue with some of our other
things that we had here this is very
very interesting
the russian uh sorry the ukrainian
president zielenski
is going to make a virtual address to a
joint session of the house and senate on
wednesday morning now this does conflict
with when
we normally film our show
i'm usually up to my elbows in show prep
at 9 00 a.m eastern
but
we're gonna try to reorganize the
filming schedule because i really would
like to cover this and take this live
would people watch if i took this live i
mean is it a weird time it'll be 6 a.m
on the west coast
but
i feel like it would be an important
thing uh ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky will speak virtually to all
members of congress
on wednesday
the speaker
and the majority leader have announced
as war rages on in ukraine it is with
great respect and admiration for the
ukrainian people that we invite all
members of the house and senate to
attend a virtual address to be delivered
by president zielinski on wednesday at 9
00 a.m
the speech is only open to members of
congress to attend lawmakers who aren't
vaccinated will need to wear a mask oh
boy
i guess we'll figure out once and for
all whether uh marjorie taylor green is
vaccinated well actually she might just
not even go
um
okay so i think i think that that's a
big deal now the only question is
whether it will be i'm sure it will be
televised live right
let me see if there's already
zelensky congress live
let's see if there's any live events
scheduled
um
not seeing any but it must be
it must be
hard to imagine that that would not be
uh taken live
okay so my plan my plan is to take that
live on wednesday morning assuming that
we can get the schedule set up
jdeded says would you consider doing a
finance youtube channel we might be
entering a time when it's key to invest
and prep for the future financially yeah
actually producer pat has been talking
to me about that and we
i i kind of already have what the first
two clips would be
honestly right now let me tell you what
the hold up is in doing a finance
channel right now okay
i want to be able to easily kind of like
do like the khan academy like i draw on
the screen type things
and i have this wacom tablet i know it
looks like wacom but i'm told it's
pronounced wacom
and i've got the stylus uh it's over
there
and i tested getting this and trying
some different software
to see if i could do it
and this thing just sucks like if i
don't touch the pad
it doesn't if i if i hover over the pad
it just doesn't feel right it doesn't
work right and if i touch the pad it
scrapes and it doesn't i don't have the
right software it's it's terrible so if
someone could email info at
davidpakman.com and tell me exactly
what's the best draw pad and exactly
what software i should be using
i am glad to buy it and to start doing
some finance content okay people
recommending i get an ipad no i have no
apple products i also need something
that connects to the computer so i i
just i just don't know how an ipad would
do anything for me
at this point in time
um
okay so anyway info davidpakman.com i'm
glad to start doing some finance content
but i need to have the right tech
elements okay
thank you very much
sir did you see the unhinged tweet by
tool c gabbard about u.s bio labs in
ukraine unhinged i i'm gonna believe me
i'm gonna we're gonna get to that that's
on the agenda for today okay that's on
the agenda for today thanks to 32 danny
pro dad build and shugs twitch prime
members three four and five today uh
very much appreciate that okay let's
continue um i would uh wan i wanna let
everybody know by the way speaking of
other types of content a lot of people
have been requesting
culinary elements
and um i am going to maybe do this if
people like it
here's just a random video i put on my
instagram last night
i filmed this while making a spanish
tortilla last night
and i put it together just while doing
it and it somehow got 40 000 views or so
i think on my instagram check this out
let me know if this content is
compelling to people
here we go
start by frying your potatoes don't
brown them though then add onion i added
a fresno chili
beat some eggs
mix in the potato mixture
put it back in the pan
flip
wow
wow
back in the pan
a little messy
then just tuck it in
tuck tuck tuck
flip
again
then
the plate
to reverse once more careful with the
plate there it is
and
flip
look at that
look at that
little piece it's clean i'll try it
very good
here's a cross section
can't beat it
so anyway um i i got a bunch of uh
amazing comments and and all sorts of
different things it i did it totally on
a whim and i have to tell you there's
all these people
who started in the comments claiming
that this was a quiche that this was a
frittata that that tortillas are the
things that you make a taco with
guys do you think i'm really that stupid
this is a spanish tortilla a quiche has
a crust okay a quiche has a crust and is
baked in the oven
a frittata
is also baked in the oven it doesn't
it's not so potato based
uh it has a lower ratio of eggs
typically
this is a spanish tortilla now i know
it's like well hold on i got a flour
tortilla for my taco it's just something
else okay
go to spain or just google it because
you don't need to go to spain to check
this out just look for what what is
spanish tortilla this is it the only
difference is i threw in a fresno chili
because i like a little heat that's all
that's the difference okay guys so every
god everybody's on my case i think i
don't know what this is
uh okay so that's a spanish tortilla and
anyway people can if it's interesting to
you you know we may we may do more of it
oh god everybody's unfollowing me on
twitch people must not like it god all
right no more food content sorry
um in all seriousness though thanks to
drewish nug wrangler and jen here for
the twitch prime subscriptions i i
appreciate that
okay
let's continue
with the
tulsi stuff so
um
tulsi seems to think people care what
she believes and she's not wrong because
she put out a statement about ukrainian
biolabs which is the new hot thing
and it got two and a half million views
so let's go through it piece by piece
here is tulsi gabbard talking about
ukrainian biolabs
literally russian propaganda here are
the undeniable facts
there are 25 to 30 u.s funded bio labs
in ukraine
according now it's first of all it's not
clear that there's 25 there are some
ukrainian biolabs supported by a program
from the department of defense which is
part of a consortium
which supports bio labs
all over the world
which research pathogens and how to
respond to a potential bio weapon okay
so
tulsi wants you to think the us is
funding the us is uniquely funding
bio-weapons development labs in ukraine
not what's happening
now what's happening
the u.s
is part of a program
that supports but does not operate
bio labs which research pathogens and
defenses
all over the world
some of which are in ukraine extensive
reporting on this by
bbc extends extensive reporting on this
by the new york times so like already
the first sentence is extraordinarily
deceptive if not dishonest
to the us government these bio labs are
conducting research on dangerous
pathogens
ukraine is in an active war zone with
widespread bombing artillery and
shelling and
these facilities it's funny because at
this point who would be like guys
we really need tulsi for moral clarity
on what should happen there it's like
what are you talking about who what i
don't know why anyone even cares what
she says but
clearly people do so we're looking at it
even in the best of circumstances could
easily be compromised and release these
deadly pathogens
now like covid
these pathogens know no borders
if they are inadvertently or purposely
breached or compromised they will
quickly spread
all throughout europe the united states
and the rest of the world causing untold
suffering and death
so in order to protect the american
people the people of europe the people
around the world
these labs need to be shut down
immediately and the pathogens that they
hold need to be destroyed now it's
completely legitimate to say
hey
what sort of security is there
when you have these labs
in places that are getting shelled and
bombed that's perfectly legitimate
but
this is all part of the
biden harris
are doing the wrong thing the u.s is
doing the wrong thing biden and harris
aren't shutting them down these are not
american labs to shut down and there's
nothing unique about the fact that these
labs are there and so with all of these
things
the way that the grifters will defend it
is to go david are you saying there's no
danger to one of these labs getting
bombed no i'm not saying that what i'm
saying is
why is tulsi putting out a two-minute
video about this and why is the entire
attitude
that this is what you're not being told
and there's something special
about these labs in ukraine there's over
50 of these labs around the world many
of them are in europe
there's nothing particularly pernicious
about it
instead of trying to cover this up the
biden harrison see so
who's covering it up what are you
talking about these are all
you the u.s publicly and by the way it
has nothing to do with biden
the u.s has publicly been part of this
consortium that supports this research
for i forget how long at least 10 15
years administration needs to work with
russia ukraine nato the u.n to
immediately implement a ceasefire for
all military action the vicinity of
these labs until they're secured and
these no no no tulsi we need a permanent
ceasefire like what do you mean
you we're gonna all imagine can you
imagine look at those people she she
listed she says we need russia i mean
the biden administration russia ukraine
nato and the u.n all need to come
together
and negotiate a ceasefire
until the labs are shut down what
no just we just need to be negotiating a
ceasefire and there's nothing nothing
special or pernicious or being covered
up about these labs but people hear this
and they think oh my god nobody's
telling us that this is going on what
are you talking about pathogens are
destroyed
in addition to all this the u.s funds
around 300 bio labs around the world i
don't even know that that number is
accurate either
who are engaging in dangerous research
including gain of function similar to
the lab in wuhan where covid19 may have
originated from
unproven
now after realizing how dangerous and
vulnerable these labs are they should
have
all been shut down two years ago now
that seems completely insane shut down
all labs
remember when uh remember when mike
pillow oh damn it
i actually forgot i have new uh
i have i have to add these remember this
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines
okay
uh
so
you guys remember when when pillow said
he was suing all machines
it's like what are you tools shut down
all labs what are you talking about so
we're gonna let the people developing
the bio weapons because those are
actually that's actually being done in
secret okay
there are
there are countries around the world
secretly doing bio weapons research
and tulsi's idea is shut down every lab
researching pathogens and how we would
respond to a bio-weapon attack
what
what what are you talking about why
would we shut down all of that that
doesn't make any sense
and the research like what it's it's
absurd
it's as absurd as my washing machine
getting sued by pillow
uh okay here's a little more
but they haven't
right they haven't because they're doing
research tools and most of these places
are in regions that are not at any kind
of risk now this is not a partisan
political issue no it's just weird
fear-mongering
the administration and congress need to
act now for the
how is the administration going to shut
down you know brazilian
biolabs
what are you talking about
it's absurd
it's it's completely absurd so anyway
mitt romney actually had a good take
which is
tulsi is parroting false russian
propaganda her treasonous lies may well
cost lives
um
i'm not a guy who is like on the romney
train for politics i voted for obama
over romney
but
if mitt romney were the worst of the
republican party
this country would be much better off
unfortunately romney's the best of the
republican party now i already know that
some grifters are out there saying well
romney never served in the military and
tulsi did what does that have to do with
her absurd parroting of russian
propaganda and suggesting all labs be
shut down
why does mitt romney need to serve in
the military to be able to give us his
opinion on that
and i think it was greenwald who started
with that
romney didn't serve in the military
neither did his kids but tulsi did
she wants all labs shut down and she's
literally repeating the the propaganda
talking points
of some russian
minister of affairs maria korokova or
something like that
it's it's just shocking it's shocking
okay so anyway tulsi is calling for his
resignation
what i love about tool c calling for
romney's resignation
is
who cares what tools he thinks tulsi
thinks someone should resign oh okay
continue please please proceed governor
please proceed governor uh mitt romney
this is tulsi tweeting
you have called me a treasonous liar for
stating the fact that there are 25 u.s
funded bio labs in ukraine which if
breached would release and spread deadly
pathogens to u.s and the world
and therefore must be secured in order
to prevent new
pandemics bizarrely you claim that
securing these labs or even calling for
securing them is treasonous no
no he didn't say that asking for secure
labs is treasonous that's not what he
said he said you're parroting russian
talking points which you are
then she said senator romney please
provide evidence that what i said is
untrue and treasonous if you cannot you
should do the honorable thing apologize
and resign from the senate there you go
so tulsi calling for mitt romney's uh
resignation i'm sure he'll take that
under advisement
it's it's really really bad out there
guys whoops crap i just closed the wrong
thing
hold on let me get that back
i closed something i hadn't gone through
yet i apologize
okay here it is
okay we'll get back to that in a moment
thank you to
gd brown
sam shung
a gift of five subs from nug wrangler a
gift of two subs from ms frazzled and a
subscription from digital rico
um
that's 10 guys that puts us at 18. i
really appreciate that and i applaud you
for that thank you very much really
really important stuff
um ferret queen says i make the same
dish but with shredded potatoes and egg
on the outside with hammer sausage and
cheese in the middle awesome breakfast
dish oh so that's a little more like a
potato pancake yeah that can be good too
that can be good too
oh and thank you to may rican for the
five gifted subs on twitch i appreciate
that as well okay
here's an interesting video clip this is
one that we missed from the
trump rally over the weekend this is
really good
i think you're gonna like this our
friend walter masterson who by the way
walter wants to be on the show i wanna
have walter on the show the streams are
scheduled so last minute
that um sometimes i don't you know we
just we it's hard to get guests but we
want to have walter on
here's some interesting uh interview
content from the south carolina trump
rally check this out i got a good idea
what's going on in ukraine when they
went into ukraine and they found these
labs they believed that made that the
deep state
is
possibly going to use a bio weapon on
russian people because they've been just
like that they were collecting our dna
in china wow
her brain is is mayonnaise
that's about six different things
that's about that's about six different
conspiracy theories
chinese covet dna collection related to
the deep state's use of bio weapons labs
funded by biden in ukraine
i can't eat guys i can't even keep that
straight
they've been collecting their dna as
well
so trump and putin right now are the
only ones successfully fighting against
the deep state i think as well as chi
too
oh xi jinping
so xi jinping is
fighting against that he's a good guy oh
so oh he's fighting against well cuz
think about it he's not part of the ccp
guys
think about it
think about it that's all think about it
[Applause]
xi jinping do you think he's working
with putin and trump against the deep
state i think he probably is yeah
probably i've heard that i mean xi
jinping is working against the deep
state
in india yeah i've heard that xi jinping
modi
vladimir putin donald trump are all
working against the deep state right and
why is that hard to believe i mean
why is that hard to believe and you've
got the white hat alliance which is a
lot of countries oh wait a second that
now that i've never heard of
the white hat
alliance
white hat alliance
white hat alliance
is a loosely associated ethical hacking
group
originated in 2011.
it there's barely any references to it i
don't know what that is
okay you know canada uh france he is
part of the good guys the reason i think
that is because he's fixing to go into
taiwan
oh an invasion of taiwan would be good
wow
that's interesting
see what i tell you when he gets into
taiwan guess what he's going to find
more labs more bio labs that is all
planned out y'all how is tulsi not all
over this now
if you told me
this was a joke that this was an actor
i would believe it right i mean what who
would doubt that this is a joke that
this is a parody
of course it seems like it must be a
joke no one could possibly have
so much mustard and mayonnaise rolling
around in their brain
but it's not it's real
oh
it's all planted this is one big sting
operation that's what i believe now if
it's a sting operation do you guys know
who they're cause a sting operation is
to catch someone
do you know who they're trying to catch
who what who's the sting on
i don't even know
fouchy yeah
right i don't yeah it's clear it's not
clear
yeah so xi jinping
putin and trump are the only ones
fighting uh against the deep state and
making sure that there are no bio
weapons that's right because if they do
not stop them they will release them and
next time it'll be far worse than any
fake chronovalves right now that's also
really funny
this is this is so this one this is
really takes a little bit of uh
you got to be like a like a
trapeze artist a rhetorical trapeze
artist
covet was fake
okay but
it was released as a bio bioweapon by
the chinese but it's not real you don't
need a vaccine for it it's not serious
but it was a chinese bio weapon and
they've done it before so they'll do it
again they'll release another bio weapon
from the ukrainian bio labs
but that bio weapon will be real unlike
the fake coronavirus
which was a bio weapon released from
china you guys understand this right i
mean
this makes sense doesn't it
it's such a convoluted conspiracy theory
it's exactly
clear as mud yeah
wow
wow i think i just lost two iq points
i think i did
thank you to unreal ronan for the twitch
prime subscription really appreciate
that okay guys you know i was thinking
the other day during the stream
someone sent a super chat and the super
chat said david sir
i'm
danish
i live in copenhagen
and i watch your show and i was walking
around and someone was wearing a david
pakman show hat
okay now
i think we should start making
every effort
to fill
the public space
with our hats and t-shirts so i'm gonna
start giving them away
okay here's the deal
i'm not gonna do this like if you're the
next person to sign up you'll get no no
no no no okay that's not it now here's
what i'm gonna do and you have to listen
very carefully i don't want problems
later okay
if you get a
full price yearly membership that's 60
bucks okay if you're paying any amount
other than 60 bucks you did it wrong
for every full price yearly membership
i will send you a free hatter t-shirt of
your choice anywhere in the world why
would you have to do it this way if you
pay a dollar for a discounted membership
and then i send you a 30 shirt we just
lose money we can't repeat that that's
not scalable okay so please listen
carefully i don't want emails later from
someone saying i just signed up for a
dollar eighty-two where's my free hot
we can't do that okay so here's the deal
we're at 24.
the first person to sign up on the
website today that would be number 25
your item is free no matter what you get
you get a monthly you get a yearly you
use a discount you don't the next one is
free okay but beyond that
anybody doesn't matter the order you pay
full price for a yearly membership
that's sixty dollars okay if you pay two
dollars and two cents that this isn't
for you if you pay full price yearly
we'll give you a free hat or a free
t-shirt what about a hoodie i'll even do
the hoodie the hoodie cost us a lot more
that's fine that's fine okay
we want to spread these around thank you
let's continue patrick for me says the
american school system for you yeah yeah
no this is this woman is very very uh
sick very sick
kb says just announced the hague has set
the date for the ruling on russia's war
international court of justice will
issue a ruling on march 16th same day
zolensky is going to be speaking to
a joint session of the house and senate
so wednesday is going to be a pretty big
day
it's going to be a sizable day
probably quite a long day i will tell
you
okay so we talked about that let's go to
this very strange interview now
um
we're going to look at an interview here
with carrie lake carrie lake is an
arizona gubernatorial candidate she is a
trumpian gubernatorial candidate she oh
wait this isn't even damn this is not
the full interview
let me see here
so this was carrie lake
60 minutes let's see if i can find the
full interview
she didn't know okay let's start with
this clip she didn't like some of the
questions she was interviewed by 60
minutes australia it's very weaponized
all right let's take a look in the media
which i'm well that's not i'm counting
you as well that's not true at all
that's not true
let's be fair on this your man donald
called our election the big lie your man
donald brought it up
your man donald said
only if you say that sir what your man
donald well well he is i mean he's
endorsed you personally
he said he said a few days ago this
woman is so gross she's so vile that
those people at the capitol should be
pardoned
they should all be pardoned
do you think they should be pardoned
i'm still amazed that you could say your
man donald that's just so disrespectful
to who
what does that mean how is that
disrespectful
she's fully trumpian and trump endorsed
her
why why would it be he's endorsed you he
you have his personal endorsement it's
just it's just the flipping attitude
it's obvious that you've come into this
it's obvious you've come in to this
interview and you don't like president
donald trump carrie it's obvious well do
you think they should be pardoned do you
think they should be pardoned i i have
no say in that i'm running for governor
this isn't something a governor does
you're trying to twist this interview
and trying to make me look bad you're a
republican he's the republican he's the
republican leader
what i don't like is that people are
being held in prison without being
charged that's unemployment
hey guys
suddenly republicans care about
pre-trial detention
we've been talking about this on the
left for 20 years
they now that the rioters are being held
they now care about pre-trial detention
practices
hallelujah right
american maybe they get away with that
stuff in australia australia australia
this is not about australia kerry this
is about
what you believe yeah perhaps in
australia because you've given your
rights away you melted down all of your
guns and you guys have no freedom that
you find that okay but here in america
the well-known uh the well-known
authoritarian dictatorship of australia
could we do things differently we have
something called the u.s constitution
right and we have rights so we'd be
better off having more guns here i mean
what you would be better off yeah you
would you absolutely would sir you
absolutely would i feel so sorry for the
people in australia have no power the
only thing keeping us imagine like
thinking this woman knows anything about
australia
she knows she's at this point she's just
grasping at anything she can from being
australia right now is our second
amendment and there's actually some
important differences between the us and
australia other than guns
australia's health care system is vastly
superior to ours
australia's education system overall
is vastly superior to ours
australia's environmental regulation
is extraordinarily superior there's a
lot of reasons why things are different
in the us and in australia
that are not because here you can
basically
all but get a gun out of a vending
machine whenever you want it never ever
let that go
mark my words what we saw happening in
australia
where you have internment camps and
people are being
forced if they've encountered anybody
with covid what did you now what is that
about let's see what that's about
australian coveted
internment camp
uh let's see here
numerous people including senator ron
johnson have made false claims that
unvaccinated people around the world are
being put into internment camps okay
johnson's office referred to a
quarantine facility in australia where
travelers have to stay for 14 days
oh okay so there was a point like a year
ago
where
if you chose to tr to come to go to
australia during the pandemic
you were allowed to only if you stayed
at a facility for 14 days yeah that
doesn't exactly sound like an internment
camp to me
to be locked into a quarantine camp is
the most horrifying thing i think i've
ever seen a government do
the most horrifying thing she's ever
seen a government do
i mean even the u.s government has done
worse things than that
it's frightening and if you if you can't
see that i feel sorry for you
would it have been better this is our
last question liam we have to run but
thank you for your time just just answer
me this one question one one more
question carrie
well no i've already told you we're done
thank you so much
that guy's a complete nut that guy is a
complete
the
nut
insane person
also what's really funny is they make it
look like they're in the same room but
they're actually doing the interview as
you can see here
she's looking at a computer which is
kind of interesting
uh anyway just just a little bit of a
side a side note there i guess uh i
guess we would say oh here's the news
about zelensky's going to deliver uh
almost like a state of the union in a
sense up the pressure on the white house
if members of congress throw their
muscle behind it to try to do something
more
so what does ukraine want well they want
air defense systems they want those mig
fighter jets that were the center of a
potential deal with poland that
ultimately fell through last week the
lawmakers in both the senate and the
house are saying hey let's get this deal
done yeah oh this is interesting liam
bartlett the interviewer is an
australian right-wing commentator yeah i
mean to me it just seems like a
journalist asking questions that should
be asked but it's particularly
interesting if he's a right winger
that's funny
uh okay who gets the first free item
today it's isaiah ortiz isaiah as the
first website member and new member
number 25 today
you got yourself a free item from our
online store email info at
davidpakman.com to collect also want to
say thank you to jennifer clayton
carrie turner
jonas hamilton milan
and sean mansfield all signing up on my
website some with the coupon code sad
trump oh hold on we need to change our
coupon code back
that's the wrong code
we're on
please don't war
there we go okay
please don't war is the current coupon
they're all you can use all of them but
okay
carrie lake was a long time news person
in phoenix have no clue she was a
trumper she's a hardcore trumpist full
full on just absolutely full full
full-on trumpist hard to believe it
actually completely extreme okay uh
madison cawthorne radical republican
congressman madison cawthorne is
doubling down
on the anti-ukraine stuff
here he was somewhere he gave a speech
or spoke to people let's listen to what
he had to say remember he recently
referred to zolensky as a thug who has
embraced wokeness
anybody else
yeah
yes sir um
we got this mess in the
eastern europe there with ukraine and
all that i know you've made some
reference to uh
president zielinski being a thug or
being you know in the government being
corrupt
we're all i think we're all trying to
figure this thing out i mean
it seems like we're on the precipice of
a
could be a possible major disaster can
you clarify some of that for us so we
know where we imagine being so okay so
like oh my god
imagine being so
deluded
that if you want clarification on
geopolitics you ask madison cawthorne
like even that as a principle is
extremely sad for the our state of
affairs
i'm not really sure about what's going
on in ukraine
let me get madison corn to explain it to
me come i mean
is there is there any hope here is there
any hope let's listen to the answer
uh i will so one as i was saying earlier
there's so much propaganda coming out on
all sides of this boat from russia from
ukraine from a lot of other countries
involved from our own media
that things are becoming so murky and
hard to understand but right but see so
that is remember the video from bryce
mitchell that's the ufc guy
who said i don't know anything about
ukraine and russia and i don't think
anybody does
this is a very common trope that allows
disinformation to be spread which is to
pretend no one knows
really really common thing very common
it's
it's so murky we don't we don't know
what's going on well a lot of things we
do know like for example putin invaded
ukraine and that's really what we would
call
the first bad act
here you can say well what about
nato wasn't ruled no no no putin decided
to invade ukraine
really murky
before we all jump to a conclusion say
we're going to go defend a democracy in
eastern europe we have to realize that
there is
the ukrainian government is so well
known for corruption
the russian government is more well
known for corruption
uh there's only it's one of the major
sex trafficking hubs of the entire world
there's plenty of sex trafficking
happening in and through russia
the
that area the ukrainian people are
wonderful people there's a lot of really
great people and those who are
patriarchy fighting for their freedom i
commend them they're doing great
um
but this is not a country that you know
i i feel like is the shining beacon of
what really truly is the standard of a
good and clean and transparent
government
whatever criticism he makes here of
ukraine
which i agree with
is exponentially worse in russia and
is that a reason to
not say
it's very clear that what russia is
doing is wrong
so like again
when you look there's one democracy
index you can find a bunch of them
there's one democracy index that uses a
score of 100
um as like a perfect democracy
ukraine's 60 and rushes at 20.
so what you have to understand is he's
saying
ukraine's not that great ukraine's
corrupt well russia's more corrupt
and ukraine's not a transparent
government
russia is even less transparent
um
ukraine has problems with uh you know
treatment of media treatment of women
treatment of gays whatever
that problem is way worse in russia but
then as we step back
it's not that these two countries
decided to get together and say let's
fight russia invaded ukraine so this is
exactly the type of
uh
it's not even really both sidesing
it's sort of like um
it's it just provides cover
to look the other way and rather than
providing moral clarity it provides
moral
cloudiness i guess i would say
and so there was a lot of corruption
that's been there you know in 2014 there
was basically a regime change that
happened uh you know there was 2014
russia also took crimea
there's just a lot of questions and
questionable issues going on there i i
know would he
say
i don't know i mean it's not super clear
if
mexico
sent tanks to the us because there was
corruption in arizona like with that
i thought that the whole thing was the
sovereignty of the borders and all of
this thing but here he's equivocating in
a really disgusting way i do plan on
releasing in detail in a few weeks just
kind of with some ideas and some
thoughts that i have on that guys
in a few weeks
madison cawthorne's gonna release some
ideas
we're screwed
we're screwed we're we're just
completely and totally screwed
uh all right so there's that
here's something interesting a woman who
works for russian state television burst
onto the channel's live broadcast
holding a sign that says stop the war
don't believe the propaganda they're
lying to you
she's now been detained by authorities
wow that's pretty compelling i gotta
tell you guys that is pretty damn
compelling i have to tell you
i like it
i like it very very much
uh okay we're gonna get to a couple of
other things here soon
uh oh a couple other people to thank
huge thank you to darren bryant
and a big thank you to
lindsay baxtrom new members 30 and 31
today really appreciate that also thanks
to milo wild and aries schmarries
for the twitch prime subscriptions
numbers 32 and 33.
we are at
uh
11 12. this is the highest we've been on
twitch subscriptions in months and
months and months i really appreciate
everybody's support
uh okay
let's do should we do voicemails or
should we do jen saki taking a really
strange question from the african
reporter what do you guys want
voicemails
or saki
we'll do both it's just a question of
the order
saki first okay so here this was just a
really weird do we know who let me
figure out exactly who this reporter is
hold on
see who this is
i don't know who this reporter is
uh okay this is
this is simon attebba
of today news africa
okay
simon attebba he always asks asks pretty
weird questions let's take a listen
and then finally
i'm trying to understand why you are
trying your end game in ukraine
you are not going there you are not
sending there there will be no flight no
no flight zone
over ukraine and are you really be a
fair assessment to say that you are
pushing these guys to commit suicide
knowing that russia has a superpower and
eventually they will capture the main
cities okay so the question he asked is
are you pushing
ukrainians
to kill themselves
that's the question
okay
let's listen to the answer when kharkiv
and all the cities are out there what's
the end game
well the end game is really a question
for president putin we have we have
completely crushed his economy uh we
have provided military assistance
humanitarian assistance to the
ukrainians enabling them to fight back
for far longer
than the russian leadership uh
anticipated uh and again he has to uh he
has determined what the path forward
looks for like for him thanks everyone
isn't that something that's simon
attebba he's actually asked a few pretty
pretty wacky uh wacky questions let me
see if i can find a couple others here
that's an interesting one is is the end
game to get ukrainians to kill
themselves
let me see if i can find some of his
other questions
not how i would phrase it but
uh
let me see
frickin countries
here's another one of these instances
there's a bunch of these
let me just go to raquel and then we
gotta wreck up raquel go ahead
simon i'm trying to answer your question
and then i'm going to go to raquel okay
can i say one thing raquel that'll go to
you simon we're evaluating every single
day we don't want these to be permanent
measures and and it is something that
the president is getting updates from
his kova team i think this is when he
was yelling that the african travel bans
were were racist
i think they were ineffective but it's
like there were there were asian travel
bans there were european travel bans you
know we the pandemic has seen travel
bans all over the place i don't think
they worked
every single day on so my question is
the the omicron variant is now in 57
countries the who issued a statement
today and said that africa has 46 of the
nearly 1 000 cases globally but 70
almost 70 countries in the world have
imposed travel ban on only black african
nation and the us is among the countries
that have imposed sanctions on only
eight african nations when the when the
variant is in 57 countries why don't you
just lift it or impose function on all
the countries that have it what will you
say to those who believe that this is a
racist ban that target only african and
black african nation simon i would
convey to you that is absolutely not the
intention yeah i think the real
criticism was that it was too little too
late i mean
the the asian uh
traffic uh uh travel ban
was too late because it was already in
europe and then they banned europe and
then that was too late uh and then
you know then it was these were
ineffective uh i don't i don't think
they were racist and then here's one
more clip
that you are looking for a job at cnn or
msnbc
uh i have uh more than enough on my
plate here and so you can't get rid of
me quite yet sorry peter for you on that
um
and so i will see you all on monday okay
that was are you looking for a job
somewhere okay um pretty pretty
compelling stuff i i will say pretty
compelling stuff
um all right let's see here i want to
say thank you to zach ferguson who just
signed up on my website with the coupon
code please don't war let's get to some
voicemails i have 1131
voicemails for you guys i need 11 000
votes give me a break no no no 1100
1100.
um
here's something from the eggman
hey hillary clinton told us that tulsi
was a russian
agent years ago right i think hillary
should write a book now entitled told
you so
wow
wow
so they were telling on the news that uh
poland was being accused of white
supremacy i just feel like it's
appropriate to like make it about
something ridiculous like this because
if it wasn't then they might find like
a real reason
hey david it's juan
so the president can raise taxes on fuel
interesting
so why doesn't biden or any president
uh raise taxes and divert all of those
taxes
to green energy
subsidies because nobody wants him to do
that
it'd be a disaster to do that
russian youtube blogger inside by the
way i'm saying it would be a political
disaster i would love it i would love it
but it'd be a political disaster russian
youtube blogger insider russia blogged
today with enforced gulag mods it was
super awkward i felt so bad for him i
don't know what that's about but i'd
definitely be interested in hearing more
about that that sounds interesting
that sounds that sounds pretty
compelling
a couple other voicemails here
these are um
let's see
i'm sorry i just leave them messages and
i didn't
even save my name
my name is rex
from mexico city i'm sorry wow
okay
david how come i haven't heard one
person talking about the solution to
their high gas prices which is
using less gas reducing demand
and lowering the price that way or is it
even the democrats can't talk about
conservation anymore i would like to
hear your thoughts yeah i mean we've
talked about when gas prices go up
either as a result of a supply or a
demand issue or sometimes it's both
and uh of course of course if everybody
reduced how much they drive by seventy
percent that would have a significant
impact most people are not just driving
around for fun is the reality so i don't
think that that's in any serious way
quickly
going to um
change the price of gas
but big picture
lifestyle things are a uh are
a realistic
aspect of uh
energy consumption
hey david pakman
why don't you shut up when you play a
trump rally troy if you don't want to
hear my commentary during a trump rally
watch the trump rally on any of the
other channels that have it don't call
me and bother me david i was banned from
the discord server i did things that
weren't the night nicest i'd like a
second chance i'm not at all involved in
the discord server moderation i don't
know anything about it
haley says is truth social just the fake
twitter everyone wanted trump to have to
limit his audience and that's why so few
people got in
uh maybe it's not really clear what's
going truth social has bombed and it's
not clear if the limitations are
technical or ideological or lack of
interest
it's just not clear jay strickland is a
new member at joinpakman.com
number 35 today jay
thank you
um
let's see
other people calling in here
um
whitney keeps calling
i i sent you a email
and i had india hack into my system
and message my chess board and stop
yesterday
um the same day
that they like had an accident and fired
at pakistan
i also have like some pakistan
you can't tell
i don't know
i don't know what that's about
hey david it's juan i got a few
questions for you
question number one
how do people that earn minimum wage or
are on a fixed income
going to be able to pay for tesla's
solar panels and the upkeep for these
things why does everybody need tesla
solar panels i don't even understand
what that's about what are you talking
about
most solar panels why i don't even know
what that's about
tesla solar panels
that's number one
number two
in 2008
a bombardment
of housing flooded the market
houses were bombarded what
there was a bombardment of houses in
2008 there were there were bad mortgages
i didn't know there was bombardment
what happened
prices of housing plummeted
now the federal government
oh wait did he say tesla's and now let
me go back if i misheard let me see what
he said hold on hey david it's juan i
got a few questions for you
question number one
how do people that earn minimum wage or
are on a fixed income
going to be able to pay for tesla's
solar panels and the upkeep for these
things oh he said oh okay okay no that's
fair i appreciate that tesla's comma
solar panels comma and the upkeep on
those things well first of all teslas
and solar panels require almost no
upkeep but that's not really the
question if we as a country decide that
we're going to get off of oil propane
and natural gas for heating and cooking
and we're going to get off of gas
powered vehicles for driving
um then
we're really going to commit to it in a
way where number one there's going to be
way more aggressive subsidies on those
things
uh and number two
um
we're going to eliminate subsidies that
keep for example gas artificially cheap
compared to what it costs in europe etc
so i don't even know that i understand
the question i mean it's not i don't
think it's about i don't think it's
about tesla's comma solar panels the
much
uh
praised competition would
kick in wouldn't it guys i mean i
thought that was the whole idea that a
lot of these people
subscribed
adam gingrich says spread more love
thank you adam
very much appreciate that
have i seen the bayrack tar song
no i i'm not going to play that now
because i don't know what it is
and i want to be i want to make sure i
don't
you know play something i'm not supposed
to thanks to tight bot
for the twitch prime subscription number
36 i appreciate that i've got a few
other voicemails of some pretty
interesting voicemails here actually i
have to say
let's see what else we've got
um
here it is
so i'd like to report a crime being
committed in greece there were like
these indian people there and they were
like sitting on the floor they were like
okay yeah that i don't know that that's
illegal and it sounds
fake and racist whitney so i'm gonna
have to move on i didn't like that at
all that's not i don't think that that's
appropriate for this show
um
let's see what else we've got
my dear comrades
you stick it up for the russians what
the hell's the matter with you
what's the matter with you
making excuses for bombing maternity
wards no no no i condemned the bombing
of maternity wards and i said if it's
deliberate it's a war crime does anybody
know what that guy's talking about when
did i stick up for the bombing of a
maternity ward
anybody have any idea
i've got some really pro does sam cedar
have as much of a problem with callers
as i do can anybody tell me
i don't know
it's very weird
very very weird
um
let's see
what else do we have
some of these are just so absurd that
i'm kind of embarrassed i don't even
want you guys to know i have some of
these callers
uh it's like i'm kind of humiliated by
it
let's see if we got one more here
from whitney
so i was doing some research about the
moon um because i know that it's like
the infj which is the same as hitler oh
no i was like that seems unbelievable um
that the move judges because
it's an entity
like if you were to look at the moon
and
like empathize with it in its character
um you would see that
it's like an extremely
open viewpoint
like there's nobody on earth that
embodies like the physical
characteristics
of somebody who judges feelings like
it's anybody know what that's about i
don't know what on earth that's about
really really
strange um trying to add a link but not
working find this is link for inside
russia
stream in the last hour subject was
going to be grocery cost that's
interesting anybody know what that's
about a show called inside russia about
the cost of groceries in russia how
could i find that i would be interested
in looking at that with you guys but i
don't really know what that is
if anybody knows what that is let me
know i'd be interested in looking at
that
uh mr pickman hi i i think the democrat
party uh
is very similar to what vladimir putin
is doing he has initiated a law
are basically to
in the la
give people 15 years for spreading fake
news
and what the russians are doing and uh
with their fake news law
sir
is basically the same thing the democrat
party is doing with january oh give me a
break dude i don't care about that okay
here's the inside russia thing let's see
i found it let's take a look at this
constantine and welcome to inside russia
really update i'm streaming from moscow
russia and i would like to welcome it
coming to the street
oh boy
ah getting ready to
here
this is unwatchable guys
these glitches are in the stream that is
recorded just so you guys know
i would like
announcing the rules
anymore
there have been new laws introduced that
basically want us to
stay lower
and by speaking up on different issues
kind of get themselves some danger and i
am sitting here in front of you and
speaking up
also am not in the same
i don't think we can do 58 minutes of
this guys let's see if it got better
later on
announcements okay it was the actions
but people in a big country
did not feel the heat
people lived continued to live their
lives as
usual as normal okay
for a week for another week for the
third week
and then my friends
the people of that country started
feeling the hit and
um i know because that country is russia
and i basically told you a very short
version of what has hap has been
happening with the sanctions in russia
and most of western companies
have left the building
i kid you not
um shopping malls are closing
are we learning anything from this like
we're aware of that i don't know uh
let's see if there's any other video
that might be more interesting
my last big mac mcdonald's leaving
russia let's see what that's about i am
here in moscow russia
at mcdonald's for the very last time
perhaps ever this is march 13 9 pm and
in one short hour all mcdonald's in
russia
will close forever i remember very well
wasn't it temporary i thought it was
temporary
the day that mcdonald's came it was very
unexpected and it was a shock to us
i was
mayor 14 year old
teenager and let me tell you a new world
opened for me the entire world is
closing down today
as a tribute to mcdonald's but what does
it mean the whole world's close i
thought it was just a temporary closure
of mcdonald's in russia what is this
about i'm going to have the very same
meal
i had
25 years ago when i had mcdonald's for
the first time
let's do it
wow
all right let's skip to the ordering if
we can
what a sad sight
i haven't been to a mcdonald's in 20
years is this what the american
mcdonald's look like as well or are
these particularly russian looking
mcdonald's or something anybody know
this is what they all look like now
basically okay
it really does have a factory feel
that's why it feels weird to call them
restaurants you know
i tried to film inside kitchen
but the employees are so angry they
started screaming at me
and i understand them
they're basically thrown onto a street
tomorrow morning right that's i mean
that's a real problem so here i guess he
gets
a slip of some kind and then eventually
presumably the food shows up i don't
know it this is this is really quite a
bit of oh here we go
and big mac
ketchup
yes i also got ketchup that time
quite a sociological experience my god
well
good old friend
it's been
a pleasure
thanks for coming to my country
thanks for helping saving us from
communism
thanks for showing
are
the way we met on january 31st 1990 and
this is
march 13th
2022. it's been 32 years
and it's finally time to say goodbye
so this is exactly what i got
back in
94 in moscow
guys he's talking to a sandwich i mean
that is this
i
i guess things must be very bad he's the
guy's talking to a sandwich
and i had
imagined that moment for so long having
my first mcdonald's
then the experience was truly magical
i came and there was a big deal about
all mcdonald's employees smiling
when they were taking our orders because
we did not smile and so yeah in russia
people don't really smile my my
i have some ukrainian friends and they
were saying you know one of the most
notable things to being in the united
states is you walk down the street and
people go hi
in russia if someone does that to you or
in ukraine it's actually a friend of
mine ukrainian his wife's russian maybe
you look at them like what the hell is
wrong with you why are you smiling at me
like that
and i remember coming to the cashier the
girl were pretty girl she actually
smiled
and i smiled back and i'm like wow i'm
in the right place you know then i got
this
and i don't like mcdonald's okay i don't
that's the best he doesn't even like it
well okay so it's a it's uh you know
he's he's grieving the destruction of
his country's economy i mean that's
serious that i understand i this
actually makes a lot more sense to me if
it's not about mcdonald's that i i now
am now i'm on now that he doesn't he
says i don't even like mcdonald's now
i'm now i'm interested
ever eat at mcdonald's i think this is
plastic food it's not good for you now
now we're talking i like this guy sorry
you know
uh but back then it was not about food
it was about the experience it's a
metaphor about touching a legend about
a symbol
about having a gulp of freedom finally
you know
finally finally about thinking it for so
long
ah
that was quite a magical experience
it tasted exactly like big mac
yeah this has gotten pretty good and now
i'm sucked in guys i i feel like it's
turned the corner
and we're now this is actually building
pretty well i have to tell you right now
nothing less nothing more
um again
yeah
but
my god
i still remember the day
and unfortunately
will he have the food at all
this is my last meal
i am full i just had
a great
texan style barbecue brisket
oh now it's genius he's like i'm not
even hungry i just had texas barbecue in
moscow
that is unbelievable this this is this
is maybe the best video i've seen in the
last couple of weeks now it was so
crappy at the beginning
then he's like i don't even really like
mcdonald's and now he's like i just had
dinner
this fantastic meal really exquisite
um
great but you know what
this is not just
a meal this is a genius
tribute to mcdonald's and this is um
also experience
i i have remembered that experience all
my life and i will remember eating this
one the bun genuinely looks like it's
plastic
it just get that actually looks like a
plastic bun
all my life and this one i have on film
french fries
ketchup you have to pay for ketchup in
russia in the united states it was free
see that's the problem uh you know we
really have freedom here the ketchup's
included
french fries
freedom fries sir
i actually went to a place over the
weekend
um
it's like a belgian fry shop type place
and i don't know if you guys know like
in belgium with the fries or the frites
the sauces sauces it's all a big deal
all these different sauces
and they give you one sauce for free at
the place i went to
additional sauces are 50 cents
just saying guys sometimes you got to
pay for sauce here too
you know out of all
fast foods
burger king kfc wendy's you know
whatever
mcdonald's has that tastiest french
fries
these are the last customers of
mcdonald's in russia all right let's see
if he actually eats the big mac at any
point in time
let's see oh here he goes
at your service does the big mac have
three pieces of bread on it do you guys
know
it almost looked like there was a third
piece of bread in there it does okay
so it's it's double stacked
it's two buns
three slices of bread and two two
patties is that what it is
it smells exactly like a big mac
right
now i always cut burgers in half i just
find it better for a lot of different
reasons is that considered a faux pas
with like a fast food burger like
mcdonald's i always cut my burgers in
half
i think it's an absolute must-do
it's not possible with a big mac oh okay
anywhere anywhere you go in the world
big macs and mcdonald's food is taste
absolutely same
[Music]
wow
did you see someone slide the beverage
in oh that did that that was that was
pretty slick i like that it looked
almost like whoever's filming realized
he might need a sip that was that was
amazing look at that let's see that
again
he's pensive
and then in it comes there it is there's
the coke
that is just genius
this might this is art
there it is
imagine this can be my last big mug
in my life ever forever okay
all right guys i have to tell you it's a
pretty interesting video i'm not it
started very very it started at like a
two but now it's like a ten for sure
um so i like that okay one other thing i
wanted to do i'm testing out a sort of
day-in-the-life type format so one of
the things i'm gonna do
is i'm gonna include
uh in the day of the life video
that i did a stream today so i'll just
film a few seconds and then we'll get to
this later
uh i'll edit it later and show it to
everybody and post it okay so we got
that that's just for my
day in the life video which i'll be
publishing later
very
very interesting video i must say
i want to say thank you to clara
thornton who just signed up at
joinpackman.com and his new member
number 37
37
super chats bessonderrain says david
sir
can you tell us a little backstory of
whitney's calls and why she continues to
call
um does she know you play them okay i
have no backstory whatsoever on whitney
she started calling months ago and calls
multiple times a day i don't know
anything about her
why does she continue to call i have no
idea
and does she even know i play her
voicemails i have absolutely no idea
she's never addressed any of those
questions in a voicemail so i just have
no clue no clue at all
lewis says david can you do a live
stream from a mcdonald's and rate the
freedom fries
i would consider
i would consider doing some kind of live
stream from a mcdonald's and ordering
fries
uh
i'm just really busy but it's cert i
would think about that that could be fun
um
i would look into that i would look into
that could be interesting i don't know i
don't know how many people would
genuinely like it but
the cho this guy's channel is called
inside russia inside russia
let's see if he has any other
interesting videos
taking my wife on a date to tech oh god
they went to texas barbecue and he
filmed it
oh my god this is constantine and
natasha
hello hello
so in the big mac video he says i'm not
even hungry because i just came from
texas barbecue he filmed texas barbecue
we are unplugging
right now we'll try and unplug we have a
couple hours and i've decided to take my
wife on a date
wow
thank you and we will ban men
okay so
i'm not seeing us
somehow all right let's see what they
order
it's also small germany
not american dressmakers that's one
seating guys
this guy might be the best youtuber in
the world this guy might even be better
than airsoft fatty i might this could
genuinely be the top youtuber
yeah
addressing
okay
do they order brisket do what do we
think do they order brisket or do they
order pork what do we think anybody have
a guess
anybody know
brisket or pork
all right let's see
oh wait what is the stuff oh god that
looks like brisket inline dancing i
think in line yes because i've been in a
bar
with country dancing in
in zainsville
and i i wonder where does the brisket
show up popular
grilled veggies um quartz bread mm-hmm
says caesar salad with brisket yes
brisket
this is the texas jewel
jewel right
guys
if they had started slopping pork down
on the table i would have been like guys
this is not really the barbecue
experience
they they got the brisket this is an
absolutely perfect video this is the top
youtube channel i've ever seen
this is the this is the best youtube
channel i've ever seen they got the
brisket all right so anyway this guy
should have way more than 20 000
subscribers i i am stunned by the
production
value here it's not even about the
quality it's just the value
extremely extremely high value
uh all right i want to say thank you to
derek gwynne who just signed up at
joinpakman.com
and his new member number 38 today
do i think china will help russia
god i hope not
god i hope not oh what about my watch
selling friend right let's just see if
roman has a new video yet um
let's check that out
uh
he did oh okay so i told you guys before
about my friend roman radkovics
he was known as the ukraine train when
we work together at circuit city he has
a new channel called crafted time only
887 subscribers he has a new episode
let's just check it out i'm curious what
he's up to
in the afternoon
[Music]
roman was my manager when i worked at
circuit city as many of you know i had
these stories from working in circuit
city so they bring in they bring in
roman
i think i was 17. he was like uh how
much older than me is he's got a i mean
he was probably 20 or 21.
and so they bring in roman
and uh
i'm selling like a big computer system
someone's going back to school we got
this big big computer system going out
i'm selling it i've got the whole family
there i remember was a friday evening
and i'm pitching the extended service
plan which was like how we made 40
literally 40 of our commissions didn't
come from selling stuff it came from
selling
warranties
and it's what we would call the big boy
it was like a 400
service plan
and uh i'm pitching it
and roman just we weren't friends at
this time he shows up and he stands like
back here
and he's just looking at what i'm doing
and i'm like oh god what what on earth
is this this i don't like this at all
it's making me uncomfortable to have him
behind me observing like this and i was
like this is going to be critical
whatever so anyway i sold the big boy to
this family it's tough to sell because
it's you know it was it was a lot of
money quite frankly for for this
extended service plan
and um they just went for it they were
like yeah sell you know we want it we
want it okay good
so they leave and i'm like this guy's
gonna be really annoying
and then he just came up to me he goes
i'm gonna like working with you because
obviously his bonus was based on me
selling service plans and computers
and uh we've we've been friends ever
since so that's the story that's the
story with roman let's see what he got
up to in miami here um still got the
jacket on though the jacket on because
it is a little chilly it's like high 60s
so yeah so that's another thing with
roman he does seem to have some kind of
temperature regulation thing going on i
mean it's miami extremely humid almost
70 degrees and he's walking around in
like a full vest
and long sleeves for the
miami antique and jewelry show
i'm bringing down uh daytona zenith
daytona that i sold to another dealer
and uh meeting here with one of his
friends
to get the delivered and paid
we'll check out some watches
uh i
think watches is here
yeah yeah i'm still in touch with roman
you think i'd be promoting his channel
if we weren't still in touch luxury
bazaar is here so we'll go see what they
got
and then
we'll go get some dinner we'll
keep you guys updated see you later
wow
i love this
anyway so he's at a watch show you know
i mean i don't think we need to like go
completely crazy with the with the
content but anyway
roman's ukrainian and so he's been doing
a lot actually fundraising and sending
sending money uh to family in ukraine he
actually has a business in ukraine which
is which is cool pac fans is a new
twitch prime subscriber i very much
appreciate that also thank you to
jennifer beaupre who is a new member at
joinpakman.com number 40 today 40.
very very much appreciate that sandra
says thanks for playing him he just got
to followers then the gulag mods came
today yes
david sir quite possibly the best thing
you've ever in the history of your
youtube videos is when you repeated
trump when he said chocolate you had the
whole family laughing does anyone
remember that
i don't even remember that must have
been a throwaway when when did did trump
say chocolate at the last rally
i actually don't even remember what that
was
let me search
trump chocolate let's see
chocolate oh the chocolate cake thing
hold on when did trump say chocolate
with the president of china you're
launching these military strikes uh was
that planned how did that come about
that it's happening right then because
right there you're saying a reminder
here's who the superpower in the world
is you have no idea how many people want
to hear the answer to this this wasn't
it no hold on so when when was it it was
at the it's the story about with she and
someone was having chocolate cake or
whatever
yeah i don't know how i could possibly
find that
here's an old one of trump saying it but
i know that the one you guys are talking
about are from this weekend
can't have weakness in the white house
they have to
respect your president when i was
president
we only had strength remember the 59
shots we took at syria
59 missiles every single one of them hit
their target from 700 miles away
and i was sitting with president xi of
china you remember having chocolate cake
at mar-a-lago was wonderful chocolate
chocolate yeah i know that he said it at
the at this weekend's rally
i don't know how i would possibly find
that if someone had the exact time code
somehow
maybe i could find it but i don't uh
i don't
remember yep
i don't know that's too bad
okay all right everybody that's gonna do
it for today we uh wait whoa whoa we
looked at a bunch of stuff we did many
things i've gotta go but um i'll work on
that day in the life video and maybe
post it and we'll go from there all
right i'll see everybody tomorrow and
then wednesday morning we'll be here for
the live zelinski address to a joint
session of congress the house and senate
will be there uh big big big things
happening this week so we'll see
everybody very soon